the monsters are back this time they're
in college yes that's right chugging on
beer taking shots off woman's tits doing
lines of cocaine taking ecstasy having
fart jokes [ __ ] on people for fun
drawing dicks on each other's faces
getting their dick caught in a pie it's
like Animal House but with monsters
monsters University I love the original
monsters inc movie but how does a
prequel stand along with this franchise
honestly it's pretty damn good is it
better than the original no but it still
feels like a fresh people I love how
they were able to take the characters
that we love like Mike and Sully
actually have them feel very fresh and
still feel full of surprises it's hard
to make a prequel to that without just
giving them information from the past
and just showing it but they still
managed to have a level of excitement
there's still level of fear level of
danger the chemistry we see Mike and
Sully although it's a different
relationship than what we remember it's
still pretty damn good but ended up a
few concerns about my consulting for
example how do they take a [ __ ] mike is
just an eyeball he eats food but where
does he go to the bathroom where does he
pee does he coo does he have a penis
could I suck his dick cuz i remember in
the original monsters inc he had a
girlfriend and you know they seemed
really in love that happened to make
love and then you got Sully who most
likely can go to the bathroom him
because he's clearly like Agatha more
human shade kind of guy but you know his
penis was probably covered by all those
blue pubic hair but anyway the most
important thing is that it actually
feels very fresh still feels alive it's
not a waste of your time like I thought
it was gonna be it's actually worth what
unions cool to see the history of how
they became best friends when they were
originally enemies there's also a lot of
great monsters too they have some really
funny characters in this movie there's
just one guy with like a billion
eyeballs that there's like a lot of
monsters in this movie with a billion
eyeballs there's this purple monster who
who will make you crack up it will make
you laugh a few times and it's a pretty
funny character but a good
watching him and the animation like how
Pixar likes to do it is fantastical the
great details wonderful imagery every
monster in this feels alive you're not
distracted going all they're a bunch of
cartoon characters you're actually
watching it go how long board I had
these characters feel very human to me
actually weird isn't it monsters feeling
human in a waiver all monsters aren't we
that's why guys and girls can't be
friends they will eventually [ __ ] or
you'll end up in the friend zone with
one of them wanting to [ __ ] him that's
some of this movies about one of my
complaints about this though is it's not
as original as it's capable of being you
know like monsters inc was so [ __ ]
original this one it kind of follows
that formula premise that were you've
seen a billion times before oh two guys
kind of working at the same place
whether it's a work environment college
or the internship you guys are enemies
at first they have to learn to come
together become friends and conquer
those goals and college together it's
predictable plot I will say the last
like 30-45 minutes has most of its
creativity in there the last 20 minutes
takes up fresh spin on what we might
normally expect this movie to end like
they actually give the character or
something to make the audience kind of
question their morale question their
integrity question who they are it's a
really neat take on a kid's movie
actually and last thing I gotta say
there's a short film before this movie
that is one of the more unique Pixar
films ever it's not as funny and vibrant
as we're used to it's more slow moving
but it's one of Pixar's most unique ones
and I recommend paying attention for it
for those with a short attention span
you will probably need adderall so
overall it's fresh it's funny animations
great it's inventive for the most part
let me get straight to the point here
all in all i gotta say monsters
university got it right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
show why don't you go ahead school that
comment box below and tell me what is
your favorite monster moving picture you
have ever seen and if you want to see
more in-depth review of monsters
University go ahead and check out my
show called reasons to see where we have
special guests around the show Michelle
q where we're going to give you a
breakdown of reasons to see and not to
see monsters University and last not
least if you want to get updated every
time one of my reviews is out go ahead
and subscribe to my channel by clicking
on the link right here by my monster
[ __ ]